today is going to be so exciting next to
me is the brand new Corvette eay now
I've done a few videos about this in the
past most recently because this is the
brand new cover car for the new fortza
Motorsport but I've never actually got
to get behind the wheel and drive it but
today that's all going to change so
let's hop
in I really want to go through a
drive-thru like maybe a Starbucks or
like a Wendy's McDonald's inn out I
don't know whatever it doesn't
[Music]
matter
[Applause]
[Music]
a I give one of those just going to be
us eating
[Music]
pretzels so now that we're inside this
interior is called Artemis and this
exterior is also a new color it's called
the Seawolf and it is so beautiful if I
was going to get this car I would
definitely do the Sea Wolf I am obsessed
with it for the interior though if it
was my car I would definitely get a
little wild and do some fun colors you
can customize so many different things
on their website and the first time that
I looked I was like okay this is
overwhelming but I love that there's so
many different options that you can
choose from so the interior of this does
have a very similar feel to a stingray
but because this is an r-ray that's
where the electrified boost comes in so
I want to give you guys a demo of
stealth mode so this will allow you to
jump into the battery mode so you
basically will not here a single engine
so this is great if you're pulling out
of your garage at like 6:00 a.m. and you
don't want to wake your neighbors so now
we're popping it into stealth mode so we
have normal we've got shuttle and then
we just cruise over here to stealth now
when I actually start the motor you're
going to hear nothing nothing's going to
happen
silence here we are okay let's drive
away it's so quiet
oh man
wow so now I'm going to turn off stealth
mode and you can hear what this actually
sounds
[Applause]
[Music]
like can I do a chicken nugget Happy
Meal what toy do you think that we're
going to get it looks like it's Pokémon
you love
Pokémon where's the toy oh my God
they're Pokémon cards no way thank you
that's so good first I'm going to Feast
on my nuggets I'd offer you one but you
don't eat meat so far this has been so
much fun we've also had a lot of
strangers coming up and asking about the
vehicle because technically as of now
recording this not really very many of
these on the road because they are just
going into production so making some
friends um where should we go next
anywhere we want sounds
[Music]
good
so one of the things that makes this car
so unique is the fact that it does have
this electrified boost now I haven't
driven that many Corvettes to really be
able to give you like some sort of
side-by-side comparison but I did
recently go to Spring Mountain Resort in
Vegas and drive the stingray around a
track so for me just coming off of that
and then taking this car out around the
street has been a really cool comparison
but what I really like is that
electrified boost now I would not call
this car technically I guess it's a
hybrid because it does have a battery
but this is not something that is made
to be driven as an electric car now it
has that electrified boost just to
really give you that extra power which
is pretty impressive especially right
off the
line what's interesting about the
battery is there is a little button
right here on the side that you can
press and as you're driving it'll
automatically regenerate the battery for
you so you don't have to plug it in you
don't have to charge it'll automatically
do that while you're driving ding so
when you're in the electric mode you can
drive up to about 4 mil or when you
reach 45 mph it'll automatically engage
the engine so it's definitely not
something that you're going to be
driving around town in electric mode I
mean you can but again only up to 4
miles or when you hit 45 mph so now this
car will go 0 to 60 in 2.5 seconds which
is the fastest Corvette so far in
history which is pretty impressive now
having just recently driven the stingray
I do feel like this has a very similar
feel to it so if you are someone who
doesn't want to stray too far away from
something that you're comfortable and
familiar with with Corvette I mean I
don't have a ton of experience driving
these cars but for me having raced this
around the track and now racing around
Los Angeles it does have a very similar
feel like the interior the seats like
everything is just it just feels cozy
and comfy another thing that's really
fun is you can record your rides now
this isn't new to the eay you could also
do this in the stingray as well but you
have the ability to go in and record
record to an SD card and you can put the
SD card right here in your dashboard and
right now it says I can record up to
1,000 hours just on this 128 gig SD card
and it does record 1080P and you can
choose what type of layover you want to
have so right now I have m in sport mode
you can change it to have none and this
will give you different types of specs
depending upon what mode you
[Music]
have going
up w
oh it's like a Transformer it's really
cool this is very nice you like to do an
unboxing of our Pokémon
cards here we go this is the good stuff
right we're driving again so I'm not
unboxing pause get a little Clos and
don't P
up oh man that was so much fun all right
Jen what did you think it so much fun
very jealous that I didn't get to drive
it you literally were like hey look out
your window this morning and I look out
my window and I'm like pick me up check
this out we've got a frunk let's see you
didn't show me the frunk oh yeah so it
does have a trunk and a frunk look how
much space we have that's actually
pretty pretty decent yeah look at this
we've got a snack
net you do have a lot of snacks back
here but since this is a convertible
version the trunk is a little bit
smaller because you do need kind of a
place to put the top for the ride though
thanks see you later bye let's oh I
guess I'll go home now um see you later
thank you guys so much for watching I
had so much fun driving the E around
today and even though I do have to give
this back I'm really really sad but
thankfully Forza is now out so I can at
least play a virtual version I
definitely look forward to hopefully
driving this around again I would love
to take it to the track and hopefully
we'll have some more car content here
cuz I'm I'm obsessed now see you guys in
the next video
bye